but we have to be cool you just brought
back a memory and a rumor our guys had
beef with one of your other factions
that group paid your group to
assassinate one of our dudes they drove
up and they shot somebody in front of my
buddy's house which ended up being a guy
from your own Camp you heard about that
yes
so it did happen
uh well okay I don't know so so it
that's that's a oh my God you cleared up
a rumor in my mind it's been in my head
for like ever that special day we were
supposed to have a rumble and and solve
[__] so they knew we were all at this
house the guys that came a different
fraction of their gang he didn't even
know that this was gonna go down he was
smoking weed at the doorsteps and when
they came up and and did the drive-by
they ended up shooting their own side
damn yeah wow oh [__] it's a rumor by
the way yeah but it's a crazy rumor but
I mean it's a room with a lot of details